hey everyone this is Steve lantro with
collider and I'm here in the Sundance
studio uh with Stephen Dorff uh I just
want a huge shout out to Saratoga spring
water for being our our sponsor costs a
lot of money to be at Sundance and I
really appreciate them
uh exact 100
um and also Hendrix
listen man I have a ton of questions for
you uh we're going to talk about
Divinity in a second but
you one of the few that has been working
for a long time as an actor and it's
really hard but when I was looking at
the always accurate IMDb I noticed that
when you were a kid you did an episode
of Different Strokes oh yeah and I have
to know what do you remember even being
on that yeah well it was weird like my
first when I was a kid and I was in
school this agent you know I started
doing commercials auditioning and then I
started going to school I mean going
getting auditions for uh all these TV
shows that I grew up watching you know
like Different Strokes Gary Coleman I
was like what so I auditioned for it got
it and then I'm on the set but he's not
in it because Gary Coleman was sick at
that time dealing with something so the
red-headed kid
um was was the star of the kid and so I
was a Cub Scout in that um
I love that I like that I was able to
work with you know I got to work with
Michael J fox to do an episode of Family
Ties when I was young Married with
Children Roseanne
and I just finished working with Goodman
on gemstones with Danny McBride and
we've been working all on that new
season and uh Goodman I said do you
remember I was a Becky's boyfriend and
you sat me down on the couch and uh
told me what time to bring her home and
he's like I remember Stephen and we
talked up and then we watched the scene
it was on YouTube and John made me watch
it it's so funny yeah I liked all those
early things because you know I was an
LA kid I grew up in the valley and kind
of ended up on all these surreal very
surreal upbringing because I ended up on
the sets of all these fake families that
I grew up watching you know when I'd be
sick from school or you know my favorite
TV shows I never got on The Love Boat
though that was one I would have loved
to have been on you might have might
have been a little young maybe yeah I'm
gonna throw that out when did you
actually feel like as an actor because
obviously if you grew up in La you're
living at home family but when did you
feel like you could be an actor and like
pay your rent and like you know what I
mean like this could what I could do for
a living yeah I was pretty lucky and
fortunate that I had a family that
didn't at first want me to be an actor
you know they wanted my mom wanted me to
do better in school which I was having a
hard time
at these private schools I was going to
in LA and my mom used you know that to
say okay if you do better in school you
can then go on your auditions you know
and then from there
you know they saved my money so as I got
these gigs or if I didn't get the gig it
didn't really bother me and my mom was
like wow he has tough skin but a lot of
the kids I was going up against you know
um their families were very involved and
you better get this job or you know you
know and it was intense it was a bit
unhealthy I thought as a kid to be have
that pressure it's already kind of
nerve-wracking to go in and read for a
bunch of strangers you know so for me I
was very lucky that all I had to do was
do good in school and then they got me
to my auditions and my mom and dad saved
my money so I guess you know when I was
16 I bought my first car my mom didn't
have to buy it for me you know I
bought a BMW and thought I was you know
hot you know uh but you know I made
that money and that was cool so I've
been making money a long time yeah it's
been it's been cool so I you you're in
today at Sundance because you have a
film inside it's called Divinity yes um
so for people listen no one will have
seen the the film yet who's watching
this yeah or maybe two people so how
have you been describing it how have you
been describing the film because I've
seen the the trailer I haven't seen the
film yet and the trailer is like uh it
looks really cool and different and not
I think what people are expecting
yeah I mean geez it's a very like
strange situation I've made some
interesting films before
in unorthodox ways and different you
know off the beaten path but Eddie was a
director that I met through a friend of
mine named Danny
um he sent me a short I watched it it
was then in can it was called the Vandal
uh it was kind of I thought mind-blowing
for 10 minutes short or however long it
was I was like who is this guy we talked
on the phone a lot
he said I want to build a movie around
you you know what do you think of this
kind of character I said well you know
what do you want to do when nothing was
really happening at the time because of
covet but sure enough I went off and
started working the World opened up
Eddie gave me like a 30 page document of
the script but it talked to me about
this character
um and frankly it's a you know movie set
in the future
um it's it's uh my God it's made like
Citizen Kane in a in a very dark very
special stock uh reversal black and
white 16 mil same film stock that pie
was made on Darren aronofsky's film and
it was very hard and there's Prosthetics
and to me the film in tone is kind of
like it always felt like a home invasion
movie set in the future
um in a glass house in the middle of
Joshua tree with nobody around is the
main premise of the film and it's a very
restraint uh torturous performance of
without having necessarily big
monologues it was a very painful
performance for me so it was hard and um
I like that and I liked the belief in
Eddie and now we're here in the official
selection I think he's about to make
some noise I think the film from what
I've seen
is really different and really strong
um you know I guess sci-fi meets Noir
meets uh you know a mental breakdown
through a IV that's going into me and
ultimately I change into a creature so
um the movie's like a you know Clockwork
Orange meets uh Elephant Man to me I in
the footage I saw it one of the things I
love about uh is when I'm seeing
something that I'm not expecting and
it's completely you know what I mean
like just looking at this in the footage
I was like oh this is so like it's it's
taking a swing you know yeah I mean very
weird performance for me I mean Eddie
wanted me to talk I tend to have a deep
voice I guess and he wanted me to talk
in a very high register which was really
difficult when I could do accents I can
do
you know I can hear things and repeat
them uh mimic them but I it was very
weird to do all my dialogue like up in
here and talk to you the whole time like
this but without sounding strange and
um you know and keeping it really
original and normal and natural you know
and so for me it was like what the hell
am I doing here you know and it took
time
to kind of for me to I think trust it
and then once the makeup was grooving
and everything then we we went on our
journey but I haven't you know me and
the rest of the cast we haven't seen the
film yet you know the finished film but
Mark manzini who was doing the sound
design I did a lot of my looping with
him and he did Dune and all these big
films and Eddie's really brought
together an incredible group of
technicians to work on a very daring
experimental film so you've done I like
that I do too actually I'm really
looking forward to seeing it um you've
done so much work over the years if
someone has actually never seen anything
you've done before uh what is the first
thing or the second thing you'd like
them watching and why
[Music]
um
I don't know maybe start at the
beginning I love the power of one my
first kind of big entry into film I
thought I mean obviously I did the gate
before so people like Tarantino and all
those guys and and Eddie even and Mike
Marino the best makeup man and every all
my friends that are you know horror
Buffs will say the gate was your first
movie and I'll be like I know but I was
seven I was 16 I was 17. the power of
one was really
my first movie in my mind as knowing
what I was doing as an actor traveling
getting out of La not being a chubby
little kid screaming which is easy to do
was always easy for me to do so for me I
guess start at the beginning and then
maybe I don't know go from power of one
and then watch somewhere and then go
watch True Detective and then go watch I
don't know check out blade if you
haven't seen it oh no so I'm going to go
see I shot Andy Warhol some of my or
entropy find the movies that nobody
knows entropy I actually want to give a
thumbs up to Phil Juan who directed uh
it's really cool it's really good
um so I believe you just worked with
Tony k
I did I've worked with Tony before you
know another
um Interesting Man an artist I think and
um unique person yeah I did a film uh
for my friend I supported my friend Vito
Schnabel who's a
big art dealer and I know his dad who's
obviously Julian and a great filmmaker
and painter and um
I worked with uh veto on this film that
he had been writing and working on for a
while and Tony ended up directing it and
Vito's in it and uh and he's got a great
group actors in there so yeah I played
with them for a few days
Tony was crazy as ever I was going to
say uh yeah I yeah
you know what I mean I'm a little
sweetheart though listen I I I'm really
looking forward to it but I um a sincere
congratulations for Divinity thank you
man being part of Sundance uh it's
really always cool to talk with you and
I wish you nothing but the best and I
hope you have an awesome Fest thanks
appreciate it man thanks for having me